en estos días todos están hablando de
inflación y deflación incluyéndome a mí
Y esto es Por qué es importante y para
poder tener una visión informada de esto
creo que es importante ver cómo se
define la inflación y aquí tengo una
impresión de pantalla de mi terminar
bloomberg de la canasta de bienes que
conforma el índice de precios del
consumidor ipc que también contempla
cosas como bonos del tesoro títulos de
protección contra la inflación Este es
el índice que dicta cuánto van a pagar
los títulos de seguridad social y qué
tan rápido van a crecer y estoy segura
que muchos acuerdos sindicales y
acuerdos de pensiones dependen de este
ipc Y esta es la canasta de bienes
subyacente que nos dice que es la
inflación en primer nivel es divertido
de observar esto ya que ustedes pueden
comparar sus propios gastos de vivienda
o de alimentos y bebidas con respecto a
lo que el gobierno piensa que es el
gasto en un hogar típico por ejemplo el
gobierno dice que un hogar típico gasta
aproximadamente el 15.7 por de su
ingreso disponible en alimentos y
bebidas el ingreso disponible es aquel
ingreso que nos llevamos a casa después
de haber pagado nuestros impuestos se
dice que se gasta el 15.7 por en
alimentos y bebidas que no suena mal
pero lo que es más interesante es que
aquí hay otras categorías más detalladas
de este gasto es decir aquí tratan de
calcular cuánto gastan ustedes por
ejemplo en frutas y vegetales en carne
av es pescado y huevos digamos que todo
lo demás se mantiene constante pero
digamos que el precio de los huevos se
eleva porque se ha puesto de nuevo la
moda de la dieta Atkins y aquí ustedes
pueden tomar una decisión informada del
Por qué está aumentando la inflación o
si es que la inflación va a aumentar y
por eso esto es interesante de ver si
ven las categorías principales está
alimentos y bebidas vivienda y veremos
más en detalle la vivienda Ya que en
general es una área bastante interesante
de analizar ya que toma una enorme
porción del índice de precios del
consumidor y obviamente se ha vuelto un
gran problema en Estados Unidos porque
es un factor muy grande de lo que causa
la crisis económica ahí aquí se indica
que la vivienda ocupa un 43.4 por del
ingreso disponible vestimenta es el 3%
transporte 15% aquí en transporte se
incluyen vehículos automotores nuevos
Qué porcentaje se usa en camiones y
autos usados y yo creo que la forma en
la que se Calcula esto es ver el
porcentaje de estadounidenses que
conducen autos usados y se compara
contra aquellos estadounidenses que
conducen autos nuevos aquí se agrega El
combustible y muchas personas Cuando se
ve este argumento de inflación deflación
hacen énfasis de que china e India van a
continuar creciendo y debido a eso las
materias primas como combustible y
aceite continuarán aumentando y Bueno
hay personas que defienden este
argumento sin embargo en los países
desarrollados El combustible y los
transportes Aunque sí tienen un impacto
en el bolsillo no es una parte muy
grande de los gastos totales
Especialmente cuando se compara con
cosas como la vivienda seguimos viendo
aquí cuidado médico
6% entretenimiento etcétera creo que la
oficina de estadísticas es quien ha
hecho esta subdivisión tan detallada qué
vemos en esa terminar bloomberg
educación en promedio de un 3% y yo creo
que si ustedes están enviando a sus
hijos a la universidad este porcentaje
que va a ser mayor pero en promedio eso
es el porcentaje que se tiene y
finalmente otros bienes y servicios como
tabaco y otras cosas y como les decía
esto es interesante de observar si
ustedes discuten con otra persona acerca
de si se puede tener o no inflación es
necesario compararlos contra estos
números del índice de precios del
consumidor para podernos dar cuenta de
Cuál es el impacto real de Cómo será la
inflación que estamos midiendo dicho
esto Si vemos la porción más grande es
la de vivienda y yo Considero que es
justo se gasta una gran parte del
ingreso disponible de las personas en
vivienda en especial en las sociedades
occidentales pueden imaginarse que si
viven en un país en vías de desarrollo y
apenas se puede conseguir comida pues
este será un porcentaje grande que va a
ser comparable con el de vivienda pero
en las sociedades desarrolladas la
vivienda es un porcentaje enorme del
ingreso Y quiero enfocarme en algo
muchas personas comentan esto incluso
Mich del Blog analiza económico global
él me hizo énfasis en Resaltar esto en
la vivienda vemos que hay personas que
compran sus casas y otras que las rentan
Así que se le da un 6% a la canasta de
la renta y se le da más o menos un 24 o
25% algo que le llaman renta equivalente
de dueño de residencia primaria este
esencialmente es un intento para medir
Cuánto cuesta vivir a las personas que
son dueños de su vivienda pero lo
interesante de aquí y quizás ustedes ya
se dieron cuenta es que usan ese término
de renta equivalente de dueño lo que
hacen Y esta es la metodología actual es
que no ven Cuánto es la hipoteca o
cuánto Les costó comprar la casa y
amortizar la durante el tiempo de vida
razonable de la casa Ellos dicen Cuánto
costará rentar una casa así A veces
ellos buscan casas similares y dicen
bueno eh Cuánto costará rentar esta casa
o incluso a lo mejor hacen encuestas con
las personas y les preguntan en cuánto
rentaría su casa lo que dar un número
más grande sin duda Pero lo importante
aquí es que no están factorizando
hipotecas reales y esto lo pueden ver en
el porcentaje yo dije Bueno si digamos
que un 60 por de las personas son dueños
de su vivienda cómo es posible que este
número no sea el 66 por al menos en
relación con este otro número que sería
cercano al 80% pero dije Bueno está bien
ya que muchas personas de hecho viven en
sus casas podemos decir que el 66 por
del promedio medio de las viviendas que
tienen dueño pueden imaginar que hay más
personas que viven en ellas Así que
podríamos ver esto como un porcentaje
personal A lo mejor con base en una
medición de metros cuadrados y esto
tendría un poco más de sentido para
darle más peso a las viviendas pero lo
interesante aquí es que este número en
especial si sumamos estos dos la
vivienda en general es del 30% del
ingreso disponible y tradicionalmente
esta era la regla que usaban los bancos
para decidir si ustedes podían adquirir
una casa lo cual no Debería ser mayor al
30% de su ingreso disponible al menos el
pago de la hipoteca este pago no Debería
ser mayor al 30% del ingreso disponible
Pero sabemos especialmente durante la
última burbuja inmobiliaria este se ha
vuelto un porcentaje mucho más grande
del ingreso disponible de las personas
así que nos preguntamos bueno por qué
esto Solo vale el 30% Bueno pues porque
usan la la renta equivalente de dueño y
no están diciendo cuánto están pagando
las personas por hipotecas así que
aunque los pagos de hipotecas estén por
los cielos o que el precio de las
viviendas estén también por los cielos
Esto no se va a reflejar en este número
del ipc como a inicios de los 80 y de
hecho Aquí tengo ese texto de la oficina
de estadísticas laborales de su página
web y de heo aquí tienen una como que
contradicción lo copié y lo peg acá y
dice hasta los inicios de la década de
1980 el índice de precios del consumidor
usaba lo que se llama el método de
precios de activos para medir el cambio
en los costos de los propietarios de sus
viviendas lo cual tiene sentido quizás
veían Los costos de las casas ahora y
las comparaban con Los costos del año
pasado y esto lo pesaban para determinar
el porcentaje con respecto a las
hipotecas de los dueños pero en general
esa es una buena forma de medirlo ya sea
con con los pagos de hipoteca o con Los
costos de las viviendas y continúa el
método del precio del activo Trata a la
compra como a un activo como una casa
Así como la compra de cualquier bien del
consumidor debido a que el método del
precio del activo puede llevar a
resultados no apropiados para bienes que
se compran mayormente por razones de
inversión Yo estoy de acuerdo con esto
si algo se compra mayormente con
propósitos de inversión Por ejemplo si
se compra oro quizás esto no debería
incluirse en este ipc ya que es
principalmente por razones de inversión
como las acciones pero después usan esta
lógica que completamente destruye este
concepto y dicen debido a que el método
del precio del activo puede llevar a
resultados no apropiados para bienes que
se compran mayormente por razones de
inversión el ipc implementó la
aproximación de equivalencia de renta
para medir el cambio de precio para
propietarios de sus viviendas para
propietarios de sus viviendas Esto para
mí no tiene sentido para propietarios de
sus viviendas tiendas esto claramente No
indica que es una compra para inversión
sería un buen argumento si se hiciera
para personas que rentan o para casas de
vacaciones pero para casas en donde los
dueños viven Esta oración no tiene
sentido con base en su razonamiento no
tiene caso tener esta aproximación de
equivalente de renta Pero toda la razón
por la que yo estoy analizando esto es
porque a inicios del año del 83 De hecho
aquí lo dice en enero de 1983 a la hacer
el cambio a esto la inflación que hemos
visto en los precios de las casas
especialmente en la burbuja inmobiliaria
que vimos Durante los últimos 10 años
para nada fue incorporada a los números
de la inflación están siendo
subvalorados y lo podemos ver aquí y no
solo están subvaloradas se le está
quitando el peso a esto y Mich De hecho
tiene un par de publicaciones al
respecto en donde realmente deberíamos
usar el índice k schiller en esta línea
de acá en lugar de esta equivalencia de
dueño Pero argumento va un paso más allá
no solo deberíamos usar el índice K
shiller pero para poder pesar este rubro
se debería encuestar a las personas y
preguntarles cuál porcentaje de tu
ingreso disponible destinas a tu
hipoteca o a otras cosas relacionadas
con ser dueño de una vivienda
especialmente Durante los últimos 7 años
y yo imagino y casi estoy segura de que
esto es mucho más grande que el 30%
indicado acá Así que no solo este número
ha sido subvaluado y el crecimiento de
este número también ya que no considera
el aumento en los precios de la vivienda
sino que todo este aspecto fue
subvaluado también para darnos cuenta de
qué tanto fue subvaluado este es el
índice que shiller cuánto aumenta o
disminuye el precio de las viviendas
vemos Que del 2001 a 2006 más o menos
las casas aumentaron de un 10 a un 15%
anual si usamos esto en lugar del
equivalente de renta y Bueno aquí no
tengo una gráfica de la renta pero la
renta no aumentó para nada con este
Ritmo De hecho las personas dejaban sus
departamentos para comprar casas en ese
entonces los bienes raíces eran bastante
estables pero del 10 al 15% y estas son
crecimiento anual eso es lo que muestra
esta gráfica del 10 al 15% Y si
consideramos este 15% con respecto a la
canasta del ipc vemos que los números
que se reportan de la inflación están
siendo subvaluados de un 3 a un 5%
anuales y mi argumento Es que este rubro
debía haber aumentado anualmente ya que
las personas ocupan más de su ingreso
disponible en sus pagos hipotecarios Así
que esto probablemente fue subvaluado en
una mayor proporción Debería ser un 40%
y podríamos decir que está subvaluado a
un 4 a
6% Y si vemos aquí Esos son los números
ipc reportados lo que que digo es que
Durante este Rango de tiempo los números
reales de la inflación deberían estar
por aquí arriba y ahora que tenemos una
deflación en el precio de las viviendas
esto es cero ahora los precios del
índice K shiller nos dicen que los
precios de las viviendas se han
depreciado en un 20% ahora Estamos
subvaluado la deflación Aunque ahora el
ipc tiene esta marca de cero si
incorporamos los precios verdaderos de
las casas y no usamos rentas como un
equivalente de estos obtendremos os aquí
un número más negativo y mish de hecho
hizo esto en su blog Les recomiendo que
lo lean busquen en Google la palabra
mish m i sh y el primer registro que
encuentren Esa es la página de mish y
Esto fue tomado directamente de su blog
lo que hizo él aquí es que graficó los
números reales de la inflación que se
encuentran en azul y encima de estos él
puso lo que él llama el índice k shiller
ipc y esto está en rojo Esos son los
números de inflación que se obtienen del
gobierno que repuntan en el 5 6% que no
es para nada bajo y es justo por eso que
la federación comenzó a aumentar las
tasas de interés justo por esta época de
hecho en el peor momento posible pero si
ven este índice en rojo podrán ver que
la verdadera inflación repuntó en el
rango del 8% hasta acá y ustedes podrían
argumentar que si estos son los números
que usara el Gobierno Federal hubiera
sido una mejor política ya que
hubiéramos detectado la inflación aquí
en enero del 2003 y ellos hubieran
sabido que estaban teniendo su política
monetaria muy floja y se hubiera podido
evitar este pozo que se tuvo En el 2007
200008 y yo incluso argumento más allá
que estos números no están reflejando la
realidad como parte de la canasta de
bienes del ipc y yo estoy argumentando
que incluso estos números están
subvaluado la realidad ya que aquí como
un porcentaje de la canasta del ipc él
tomó esos números del ipc y los
reemplazó cambiándolos de esta manera
dejándolos como los números ipc actuales
pero si lo valoramos con respecto a lo
que gastan las personas de su ingreso
disponible cuánto gastan en los pagos de
hipoteca Yo diría que esto luciría a
algo así y hubiéramos visto la verdadera
inflación repuntar aquí probablemente en
el rango del 9 o 10% y yo creo que hay
mucho comentario social a este respecto
un argumento Es que muchos de los
pasivos de las corporaciones o del
gobierno están indexadas con la
inflación tenemos un índice de inflación
de
pasivos y por otra parte la venta de
viviendas esencialmente transfiere
riqueza de una generación a la otra
Especialmente cuando se tiene un gran
aumento en el precio de las viviendas
Así que si Hubieran hecho esto a
propósito y yo creo que así fue fue para
permitir una aumento dramático en el
precio de la vivienda lo que permitía
transferir riqueza de la nueva
generación de compradores a la vieja
generación de compradores de manera que
ayudara a subsidiar a los retirados y al
mismo tiempo al quitar esto del ipc
permitiría que los pasivos del gobierno
y de otras corporaciones bajaran ya que
ahora se inflara el índice de seguridad
social si estos números del ipc no
aumentan no se tienen por qué aumentar
los números de la seguridad social y
pueden esto incluso proyectarlo a las
personas Pueden decir bueno la inflación
determina que nos está yendo mejor de lo
que les fue a la generación de nuestros
padres Ah pero por cierto solo puedes
comprar un tercio de la casa ahora y
hasta cierto punto esto ha sido
propagado Aunque obviamente ahorita todo
esto se está derrumbando pero el
beneficio de esto Si es que yo pudiera
dar uno es que el índice del ipc Es una
herramienta creada por el gobierno
basada en una encuesta que de hecho no
ha sido la misma encuesta ha cambiado
durante el tiempo y ha cambiado de
maneras que impactan significativamente
los números que se reportan y hasta
cierto punto juegan en lo que yo creo
que es lo que el gobierno quiere que
piensen las personas nos vemos en el
siguiente
video